hey everyone welcome back to the channel
today we're going to be building out a
distributed job scheduler now about 3
days ago I put a lot of thought into
this video but since then I decided to
procrastinate and record on Saturday
morning meaning that I went 0 of3 at the
bar last night and I'm now brutally hung
over uh so I'm going to free ball this
thing and we're just going to see how it
goes all right I've procrastinated
enough let's do this so what is a job
scheduler at its core well really all
it's doing is basically you taking some
piece of binary or you know some EXT to
execute on some sort of computer putting
them up somewhere and then basically
allowing us to run them on some other
node so for example let's imagine that
we actually have one that is a dag or a
directed a cyclic graph what that might
look like is this lovely oblong
structure right here where uh you have a
3 P.M Cron job another 5pm Cron job and
then once those both run successfully
you can actually run this node over here
because it actually depends on the
execution of the both of them so the
whole point of the dag is that it is a
cyclic meaning you know uh once one node
finishes and another node finishes
eventually we can complete the whole
thing you're not running in an infinite
Loop there is actually like a completion
process here cool so let's talk about
some quick problem requirements to
formalize this thing out uh the first is
that basically we want to be able to run
uploaded binaries uh upon a user request
right so the binaries will probably go
in an object store like S3 I'm now
realizing that I didn't draw this in my
final diagram but I'm going to say it
explicitly now so that everyone
remembers the binaries go in S3 you
access them from S3 on some sort of
exeutive and then you run them there the
next thing is that ideally every job
just runs once in practice we're going
to find that this is very very hard to
do without a series of two-phase commits
which would make this whole thing very
slow and perhaps infeasible so we're
going to talk about ways that we can
ideally mitigate the effects of running
jobs perhaps more than once while you
know basically acting as if they had
only run once okay number three is that
user should be able to see the status of
their jobs um if I'm running a a binary
or I want to you know run it on some
sort of KRON schedule I need to be able
to know uh whether it failed whether it
succeeded what the error messages were
things like that and then so besides
just running things uh on a cron we also
want to be able to run dags so that's
like I mentioned a directed a cyclic
graph of task schedules so you know
we've got one dependency here another
dependency here and then that's going to
lead us to be able to run some other
task and uh I'm not going to go too much
into capacity estimates because at the
end of the day if you're making a job
scheduler it's going to be different for
every company that you're doing it for
um but we are going to be running
millions of jobs a day and so as a
result of that this thing needs to be
fast because if it's not fast and it's
not highly available uh many developers
in our company are going to have
problems with their jobs and then uh
we're going to be in a lot of
trouble cool so let's first do a high
level overview uh because someone in my
comment section told me that uh
everything I say is incomprehensible
unless I present this way so we're going
to go ahead and do that so we've got
some sort of of recurring task scheduler
right so that's going to be useful for
our Crown jobs which are basically
saying you know run once a week run once
a week at 3 p.m. on a Monday uh our dags
which are the graphs and then that is
basically going to take tasks and put
them in our scheduler node so we've got
some sort of schedular table which is
getting pulled let's say once a minute
or once every 30 seconds or something
like that and then all of the tasks in
that 30second batch that we decide hey
we actually want to run these we're
going to go ahead and send them to an
executive which is basically going to
read from three that binary and then put
the job somewhere in some sort of status
table which we'll call our job history
our status table that eventually if I'm
a user I can go ahead and read from
cool okay so the first couple of t uh
things that I'm going to talk about in
this video are actually going to be task
scheduling right so that's going to be
the process of well if I've outlined
that I want a certain task to run on
every interval or within a part of a
directed asly craft how am I actually
going to get them from there into the
scheduler
node cool so oops scroll a little bit
too far the first thing that I will talk
about is the actual cron task scheduling
right so the idea here is that let's say
I want to run this job every Monday at
noon we can have two tables right we've
got one that actually just outlines the
settings of the Cron job so the metadata
of it when we actually want it to run
maybe the ID of the overarching parent
job and then we've got a second one that
actually uh includes the scheduled tasks
that's a result of it so when I first
create a task my proposal here is to
basically at first we're going to put
one event in the cron jobs table saying
we're going to run this thing every
Monday at noon and then we're also going
to put another event in the scheduled
tasks table saying hey this upcoming
Monday at noon we have to run this task
right so just just the the soonest uh
next upcoming Monday at noon we're going
to put in the task table and we're both
going to do this on first upload now
note here that um I'm kind of making
this look like I'm using two-phase
commit eventually in my final diagram I
will reveal that I'm going to uh bait
and switch you guys and use change data
capture to do this type of thing where
you know we'll basically have this guy
doing some change data which goes into
this guy but the gist is eventually
what's going to happen is our executive
is first going to pull from our actual
scheduled task table right this is step
one right here it's going to see that
we're running this thing at noon today
and so step two is that it's going to
now uh go over to the cron jobs table
and then after it's run the job it's
going to basically say okay this current
version or this current iteration of the
job has been successfully completed
completed now go back and put uh the
next iteration of that Crown job in our
scheduled task table so that would be
noon for next Monday as opposed to this
Monday so yeah basically the idea here
is that the executive is going to
schedule the next Crown instance
shouldn't be too hard the thing that's a
little bit more complex is actually
going to be scheduling dag jobs so the
way that I'm going to propose doing this
after doing a little bit of research is
basically that we want to have some
dedicated database table devoted to Dax
now I suppose you could do all of this
in the scheduling table uh but I don't
think that would make our lives very
easy and I think it would lead to a lot
of clutter in that table which we want
to be relatively fast because we're
going to be polling it all the time so
let's imagine we've got the following
setup for a dag we've got jobs 1 2 3 4
and five one and two are going to be the
root nodes over here and they're
triggered at 3:00 and 5:00 p.m. uh
respectively job three depends on the
completion of 1 and two job four depends
on the completion of job three and five
also depends on the completion of job
three
so the way that I'm going to outline
this in some sort of database table is
as follows so I'm going to have my job
ID I'm going to have the cron schedule
if it exists there should only be a
Chron schedule for those kind of um you
know root nodes at the top of our dag we
should have uh some concept of who the
children are the reason I say this is
because you know when I finish job one I
need to now know okay I'm going to job
three and I'm updating that one of our
dependencies is finished right so when I
finish job one I now need to go to the
ID3 which is over here and I need to say
ooh you know what my dependency for job
one is finished so now instead of epoch
uh zero for job one that I've seen I can
actually cross that out and put in an
Epoch one and so by doing this let's
imagine now that job two finally
finishes as well it's 5:00 p.m. and we
schedule it we see oh we've got a child
node of three so I've got to find job uh
job ID 3 in the table and I can see the
job two is the one that just finished
maybe uh this particular Epoch was epoch
one and now what I can add is some
additional database logic you know
within my transaction to basically say
okay well if all of the dependencies are
now once again on the same Epoch I now
have to schedule this job so because job
three has all of its dependencies on
Epoch one now I can say o it's time to
run Epoch one for job three so when job
three gets run I'm now going to see its
children or job four and job five and
I'm going to go over here respectfully
and say ooh three was just run with
Epoch 1 now I can see that all of the
dependencies for uh job number four have
been run I can schedule it same thing
applies for number five we just ran with
Epoch 1 so now I can go ahead and
schedule it so the one other trick that
I'm adding here is that uh again we do
need to eventually schedule jobs one and
two again because these guys are on a
Cron job schedule and the way that I
said that worked with all the KRON stuff
was that you basically have to have the
executive reschedule again so what I've
done is I've added like a little uh mini
trick here where I'm basically
considering um jobs one and two are root
tasks as actual children of jobs four
and five and so by doing that you know
we can actually say that jobs 1 and two
have dependencies of jobs four and five
so that way I will only schedule jobs 1
and two over again once four and five
have run successfully so that way we're
not you know running multiple iterations
of the dag at the same exact time cool
so hopefully that generally makes sense
here okay if I'm going to actually
outline this is a formalized process the
main idea is that again all of these
things are going in the dag table uh the
roots of the dag are going to first be
scheduled when I first upload the dag to
the table with Epoch one that's just
going to go right in the scheduling
table uh as far as figuring out what the
actual roots of the dag are uh depending
on how you accept um the input from the
user you may need to do something known
as a topological sort which is basically
taking your dag and figuring out which
nodes have dependencies on other nodes
and then figuring out which can be run
right off the bat and which need to wait
for other nodes to run cool and then as
we complete those tasks basically what
we want to do like I mentioned is just
Mark that their Epoch is completed in
all of their children
nodes so that's going to be some sort of
atomic transaction right there because
we have to uh modify multiple rows at
the same time and then finally when all
of those dependency tasks have an equal
Epoch for a given row right so if I'm a
node three over here when I see that
both node one and node 2 are on Epoch 1
that means I can run uh the uh job three
for epoch one so I can go ahead and
schedule that task and then finally once
we complete all of those Leaf node tasks
we can re-trigger Our Roots again but
and the way we model that is by
basically acting as if this guy is a
child of both four and five and that
this guy is a child of both four and
five cool so there are going to be a
couple of edge cases here right so let's
say job three were to error out now all
of a sudden I have to actually propagate
through job three and still acts like
job four and job five were completed
albeit with errors so so that one and
two get rescheduled again for their uh
for their Chron schedules cool so as far
as the table choice for the dag table
because we have started to uh speak
about this a little bit um I do end up
saying that we use my SQL here however
I'm eventually going to go back on this
which I'm now realizing because I made
this video over the course of two days
but the gist is we do need atomicity uh
because we're updating multiple rows at
the same time so we are going to want to
be able to use transactions uh and
ideally we don't want to be doing
distributed transactions right we want
to Shard our graph or rather Shard our
data
such that one graph is completely
encompassed on a single node otherwise
we're going to have to be doing a bunch
of two-phase commit to modify most of
these rows at the same time like I
mentioned as well in the case of an
error we basically have to propagate
down all of the children of that
particular error node to mark them as
completed albeit with an error because
they can't run and uh as a result of
that that's another example where we're
just going to have to update many many
rows at the same time number two is that
we want to do all of these updates on a
single node like I mentioned that's just
going to be how we Shard and so we want
a table that uh supports transactions
we're just going to sh it on our dag ID
I say my SQL here but I think ultimately
that I've chosen that we should go back
on this for a couple of reasons uh I
think is going to be the better
choice because it's going to enable us
more data flexibility in terms of how we
actually want to represent our dag uh
is obviously going to be a
document-based database where you can
use Json and so you know in my SQL
depending on how I want to represent
these dependencies and these children
over here I think I would lose a little
bit of flexibility compared to Mango so
that's ultimately what I end up using at
the very end cool as far as the
scheduler table goes uh this is kind of
going to be the main part of the job
scheduler this is what I want to focus
on the most so we've got our job IDs
that's going to be our primary key we've
got our S3 URL which is where the binary
is going to be located in S3 right I
have to basically put in a binary to S3
to say the executive can go download
this and run it and then also we need
some sort of run timestamp so the
interesting thing with this run
timestamp and I'm going to add one more
column obligatory called status which
we'll talk about a little bit later but
the main thing with this run timestamp
is that basically it's going to tell me
when to run my job so let's say it's
2011 for my run timestamp and now I
happen to notice when I'm pulling the
database that it's 202 I'm going to say
oh shoot you know what it's time to run
the job however there are a few things
that are nuanced with this runtime stamp
at every step of me handling the job I
actually want to increase the runtime
stamp by a little bit so let's say I
finally get this job on an executive I
might say okay I'm going to increase my
runtime stamp by 5 minutes because if
for some reason that executive fails we
actually want this runtime stamp to
indicate a timeout time and if you know
if we just keep 2011 the entire time
we're going to keep retrying this job
although it may be running successfully
what we want to do is add a few minutes
to it so that you know if our job times
out for some reason we'll retry it but
we aren't just retrying it at every
single iteration so the main idea here
is we index everything by a run time
stamp so that we have a relatively quick
query on this database to quickly find
all of the jobs that we need to run so
you know let's say the current time is
206 I know that both of these guys
should be run because the run time stamp
is less than that that being said you
know if maybe an executive handles this
guy and it switches it to 215 and it's
currently 206 I know I'm not actually
incing this job right here cool and then
again like I mentioned every step of
actually running our job we want to
update that run time stamp to reflect
how much time we should wait before
timing out and basically retrying the
job in its
entirety
cool so another thing that I want to
quickly talk about is actually ensuring
the performance of our scheduling
because at the end of the day we're
reading this table a lot there are going
to be a lot of things in this table and
we want to be sure that it's relatively
fast so there are a few things that I've
thought of doing uh in order to make
sure that all of these reads are going
to be as fast as possible uh the first
is going to be that we could keep our
data in memory that might not be the
best idea just because there's going to
be a lot of tasks to schedule like I
mentioned billions and so as a result it
could get a little bit expensive to do
that um but additionally keep in mind
that besides actually just reading all
of these tasks we're actually constantly
rewriting these tasks too and as a
result we're reordering our index
because of the fact that um you know
we're rewriting all these timestamps and
we're basically reordering a sorted list
all the time which can get a little bit
of uh expensive right because these are
all going to be uh basically rights
where we have to resort our list based
on the updated time stamp that we just
put on this job and then we're also
simultaneously reading from this table
and we're reading the whole uh the whole
thing more or less to to get a sense of
which jobs we want to run and so in
order to read that table we have to grab
a bunch of locks and in order to write
we have to grab a lock on that row to
write so we're going to have a lot of
contention there so we want to be pretty
smart about this so I think
realistically the the two most likely
options here are going to be one we can
have many different partitions of the
schedular table because why not there's
no reason that we can't just have you
know 10 different scheduling databases
and having them all have something
pulling them and then incing things to
executiv as we need and another possible
option is that if we really want to
avoid grabbing any locks uh to read from
the node that we're sending all these
rights to we can actually read from a
read only replica of the scheduling node
that being said in my opinion uh this
can get a little dodgy just because you
know what if our leader goes down and
then we don't see an update in the
replica because we're not using strong
consistency or something like that that
being said um we do have a retry time
stamp so the main consequence of this
would actually be that we probably end
up just retrying more jobs and uh yeah
it's it's not the worst idea either I
think this is something that's feasible
too cool as far as load balancing goes
this is another key aspect of the
problem so the question is we've got all
of these executors right here all three
of these random nodes we can run the
task on pretty much any of them how do
we ensure that we're getting the most
usage out of our executors as possible
and that you know one of them's not just
sitting idle so option one and this may
be a little bit naive would be to use
something like a load balancer so in my
opinion this isn't going to be too ideal
so the reason for this is let's say we
did some sort of consistent hashing so
that based on a job ID we assign a task
to a specific executive node well it is
possible that one of those nodes could
just get a super long running job and
then all of a sudden now we're trying to
push more jobs to it but we can't you
know we have to wait for that first job
to finish so you might now say to
yourself okay well consistent hashing
obviously isn't good here the load
balancer should have a sense of
basically you know whether every single
executive is running or whether it's not
and in my opinion that's also a little
complicated because now we've got every
single executive having to send a bunch
of pings to just one place to basically
update its status and that is going to
be not ideal because that's a lot of
load for one node to handle the node
being the load balancer so it kind of
becomes a point of
failure option two is to use some sort
of message broker and this is a little
bit easier because now all of a sudden
the messages get routed right to that
executive so out of our message Brokers
we have two different implementations of
them and I'm going to go through them
quickly the first is going to be a log
based message broker like Kafka and so
typically what we would do there is we
would do one consumer per partition
however even this is not going to be
great because let's say you know we've
got a B and C in our Kofa q a takes
super long to run now all of a sudden
our executive is stuck running A and B
and C are stuck in this partition right
they've already been put here and no one
else can read them because we have one
consumer per that partition we might
have a second executive sitting here it
could have gone through its entire cofa
que and it can't run uh it can't read
BNC so actually in the case of something
like a job scheduler what we wouldd be
better off doing is using something like
an inmemory message broker now you may
be thinking to yourself This actually
looks like a very similar design pattern
to what we did on YouTube right where we
do all this pre-processing of the videos
encode them in a bunch of different
formats and uh in order to do that
because we don't really care what are
doing the encoding it's kind of the same
idea we're using this inmemory message
broker to actually do our load balancing
for us so basically the idea here is we
have got a bunch of different consumers
reading from this message broker and
basically when they're idle that is when
they're going to take a task off of the
queue so this is going to make our life
a lot
easier ideally as well you know because
it's in memory uh it is going to be
relatively low latency um and just
quickly return tasks over to those
executiv to be
dced cool so another thing to note is
that at first I've been acting like all
executives are equal and the reality of
the world is that they are not uh
certain times you might have more
expensive Hardware on certain executors
others might have more inexpensive
hardware and it is possible that in some
cases we might want to Route certain
jobs to certain executors so in this
case we could actually use multiple
levels of these cues right so all of
these would be different active mq
instances or rabid mq or some other JMS
implementation and so the idea here is
that we're actually going to be
scheduling tasks just like an OP
operating system does so in operating
systems you have something called the
multi-level priority cue where basically
you try and run a task on some sort of
resource uh and if you're unable to do
so within a certain time limit you
actually basically just you know say
screw it I don't really care what this
is going to return me and then recue it
onto a higher priority level queue which
is you know it's going to be more likely
to be run and in our case we could
actually have the more powerful
executors reading from those higher
priority level cues so let's say you
know our lowest level executive is going
to have a 10-second time out so that if
we have some sort of really expensive
job that can't finish in those 10
seconds we say you know what screw this
we're just going to retry it and then
we're going to retry it on level two
with a one minute timeout still can't
finish screw that we're going to retry
it on level three with a 1 hour timeout
and so level three you know these
executors over here maybe have more
expensive
hardware and then additionally note that
those guys should also be reading from
the level two and the level one cues
because at the end of the day if there's
nothing in level three should be able to
take on more work they shouldn't just be
idle so ideally they should prioritize
running the jobs from the level 3 q but
uh if there's stuff available in level
two and level one they can go ahead and
do that too so the point of the
scheduler here is when we're actually
retrying a job we can keep a count of
how many times we've retried it and use
that count to actually determine the
priority level of the of the message cue
that we're going to send our job
to cool so as far as job completion goes
what do we want to do about this well if
we have a scheduled job a user needs to
be able to query its status right we
need to know whether it completed or
whether it failed or whether we need to
retry it and uh the reason for this is
so that we don't retry it further right
if I never mark my job in the scheduling
table as completed or failed or I never
remove it from scheduling table uh we're
just going to retry it an infinite
amount of times and that would be bad so
uh what we can do like I mentioned we're
going to add some sort of status column
to our scheduling table uh and basically
the gist is like I mentioned uh we're
going to retry jobs based on their time
stamp but also if a certain job um you
know has a status of completed or failed
it implies that we've run it as much as
possible and that we shouldn't retry it
and so basically the gist is here now as
opposed to just indexing on our
timestamp of the job we should index
both on the status and the time stamp of
the job so that way uh you know we just
basically want to ensure that we're only
running jobs where the status is not
equal to completed SL failed and the
status is just equal to either like a
null or an in progress or something like
that
and then the idea is that users should
be able to query this table to see the
actual job status now keep in mind that
this table is also going to be the same
as our table that's actually doing the
job scheduling and so we want to
minimize the load on there so at least
in my opinion I think we should probably
have some replicas only or basically
some readon replicas that the user
should be able to read from as opposed
to having to read from that main leader
scheduling table because otherwise we
can really slow down our performance
doesn't really matter if a user you know
it takes him an extra 30 seconds to see
the status of their job they just want
to be able to see it eventually and so
eventual consistency should be fine here
uh as far as partitioning goes I think
uh some combination of time range for
this scheduling table as well as just
some random number based on the job ID
you know you can hash it uh would be
good to distribute out the load across
all of these scheduling
tables cool so the last aspect of this
video that I'm going to talk about is
actually going to be how we run our jobs
and ensure that we do so just once so
the main point here is that uh we have
all of this retry logic built in right
from our scheduling node we've got uh
these time stamps and so as a result of
that um not only are we prone to
retrying jobs multiple times we don't
need to but also it's possible to due to
network partitions or network failures
that we are just going to end up running
things on multiple places so what would
be example number one let's say this is
an
executive and the executor dqs from our
active mq or Robin mq
and then the acknowledgement going back
to the que to say hey take this thing
out of the queue never reaches it right
it breaks down well the queue is now
going to deliver that over here as well
to another executive now we're running
it TW uh two executiv in the same time
option two is we've got ourselves a
scheduling node uh the scheduling node
just you know uh the job is taking too
long to run it retries it because the
time stamp has run out or or rather the
the retry time has now been reached um
option three is active Q active mq just
goes down and so again we reach ret try
as a result of that option four is that
one of the executives go down and we
retry as a result of that so again uh we
have a lot of different places where
because of our fault tolerance uh we are
prone to running jobs more than once
cool so what our retries are going to
ensure is that everything runs at least
once but what we want to ensure is that
it runs only once well can we do that
well the big thing that we actually want
to avoid in my opinion here is going to
be running the same job at at the same
time on multiple places because then you
can actually start overwriting state
right so let's say uh the job has some
sort of side effect where you write to a
database uh or you're reading from a
database and writing to some rows as
well if two things are running at the
same time then they can start
conflicting with one another and it
might corrupt the state of the job so we
definitely don't want that to happen how
can we stop it the answer would be a
distributed lock so we would have
something like zookeeper over here which
as we know is basically uh a mini
database or a mini distributed log that
uh you use consensus between the nodes
to achieve it so that way we can be sure
that uh if we're reading from the same
leader that we're achieving strong
consistency if we're uh you know reading
from The Zookeeper leader and so what we
can do is our executiv can go ahead and
just grab a lock for the job ID that
they care about and then that way only
one of them is going to be able to run
it at the same time now it is
unfortunately the case that zookeeper is
not going to be perfect here either the
reason being that we probably do need a
TTL on these locks because let's say I
grab this lock for 22 and then my
exeutive goes down I do want to be able
to rerun this job right like I don't
want to have that lock grabbed forever
and then 22 is never going to get run
but by virtue of having a TTL it does
mean that if this thing is taking too
long and it loses its lock now all of a
sudden this guy can come up grab the
lock and then if this guy comes back now
they're both running jobs at the same
time so again nothing is perfect in this
situation it is always going to be the
case when dealing with distributed
systems that you're prone to just some
sort of ridiculous failures nothing can
be super robust unless you're using
something like strong consistency and
then our performance would be really
really bad now it is the case that you
know it's not the end of the world if
two jobs do happen to run at the same
time right like we're we're not talking
about human lives here uh but you know
your developers is going to look at that
and be like what the hell happened to my
job I can't tell why this thing failed
they'll rerun it and then hopefully
everything goes better that
time so another question is well we can
stop jobs from running at the same time
can we make sure that we're only running
jobs exactly once so like I mentioned
jobs are getting triggered pretty re uh
pretty frequently based on those
timeouts and that kind of retry Tim
stamp uh so the question is what can we
do to actually stop that from running
more than once in the erroneous
situation where we actually retry a job
that we shouldn't
be well option one is that we always run
jobs on the same executive note that I
write dumb right here because it is uh
the whole point of the job scheduling
service is that you don't care what
Hardware it runs on or rather that you
run on any hardware that's available so
to have to basically limit yourself to
running on one specific computer kind of
defeats the purpose of the job scheduler
you could just run it on your own
computer at that point number two is
that uh basically somehow all the nodes
would have to basically check our
scheduling table when they get a job to
see if it's been completed uh but note
that that is basically prone to all
sorts of race conditions that's not
perfect by any means uh another node
could just upload to the status table
saying the job is finished you know
right after a second node starts running
it and then the third option is that we
could make our jobs item potent or deal
with the consequences of not making them
item potent is it the end of the world
if I send two emails to my user probably
not uh and you know for things that
actually have important state we should
probably make them item potent if we're
syncing to some database uh it should
probably be that our jobs are
deterministic for the time that we're
running them this is just generally uh
you know good practice when running
batch jobs so this is probably how I'm
going to cope with the situation and
just say you know make deterministic
jobs or you know deal with the fact that
your jobs are not deterministic
cool the final thing that we're going to
go through is my diagram this is the one
that I made this morning so if it is uh
incomprehensible due to my hangover I
apologize in the service like this
there's basically two main things that
we can do right the first is that we can
inq jobs the second is that we can get
the status of the jobs that we've inced
so like I've mentioned we've got one
table to handle all of our dag metadata
another table to handle all of our Crown
metadata and I mentioned that when we
upload a dag nice voice crack Jordan
when we upload a dag or when we upload a
cron what we want to do is also schedule
the first instance of that dag run and
the first instance of that cron run into
our actual scheduling table over here
now we could do this with a two-phase
commit and that definitely wouldn't be
the end of the world because the end of
the day it's just one upload on the part
of the user um but to over optimize
things I've decided to just use change
data capture the reason being that now
we don't have to do a two-phase commit
and I do know that eventually this thing
is going to flow through Kafka flow into
basically our consumer of that change
data and then into our scheduling table
great so from the scheduling table once
we have all of those tasks in queued we
know that we're running them on some
sort of interval by having some sort of
schedule node polling the table running
that query and then putting them in our
active mq priority cues for executiv to
actually run those jobs additionally
we've also got some readon scheduling
replicas which we're going to be using
for our job status uh for users right
because I mentioned if the user is
actually reading from our main table
over here now we're adding a bunch of
additional load and that's not
necessarily a good thing we want that
polling process to be as fast as
possible so that we can enue as many
jobs as possible in a short interval um
another thing to note is that when
executiv do finish tasks they have to
update their actual status so they can
do that over here in the status table
additionally for dags we basically need
to figure out oh well besides actually
updating the status of my current job
does the triggering or rather does the
completion of this job actually trigger
other tasks in the dag so in order to
figure that out you actually have to go
all the way up here over to your dag
table uh you would go ahead and update
the epoch numbers accordingly as we've
mentioned and then that again can then
flow through our change data capture
through Kafka through our dag task
queuing node and then back into the
scheduling note so hopefully this mostly
makes sense um I feel like I've
explained it uh in the previous slides
as well and uh yeah my head is killing
me a little bit so I'm going to jump off
but have yourselves a great week guys
and I will see you in the next one